so if you look uh 10 point fsd
10.6 just came out recently 10.7 is on
the way
maybe 11 is on the way somewhere in the
future yeah um we were hoping to get 11
out this year but it's uh
11 actually has a whole bunch of uh
fundamental rewrites on the neural
neural net architecture
um
and some
fundamental improvements
in creating vector space
uh so
um there is a some fundamental like leap
that really deserves the 11 i mean
that's a pretty cool number yeah yeah
eleven would be
a single stack for all you know one
stack to rule them all um
and uh
but but there's just some really
fundamental
uh
neural net architecture changes that are
that that will allow for
much more capability but but
you know at first they're going to have
issues so
like we have this working on like sort
of alpha software and it's good but it's
uh
it's it's it's basically taking a whole
bunch of c c plus plus code and and and
deleting a massive amount of c first
plus go and replacing it with the neural
net and you know andre um makes this
point a lot which is like neural nets
that kind of eating software
you know over time there's like
less and less conventional software more
and more neural net uh we're just still
software but it's you know
still comes out the lines of software
but
uh let's just more more neural net stuff
and less
uh
you know heuristics basically um
if you're
more more uh matrix based
stuff and less uh
heuristics based stuff um
and um
you know like like like one of the big
changes will be um
like right now the neural nets
uh will
um
deliver
a a giant bag of points uh
to the c plus plus or c and c code yeah
um
we call the giant bag of points yeah uh
and it's like so you got a pixel and and
and and
something associated with that pixel
like this pixel is probably car the
pixel is probably lane line um then
you've got to assemble this giant bag of
points
in the c code and turn it into uh
vectors
um
and uh it does a pretty good job of it
but it's
it's a
it's
we want to just we need another layer of
neural nets on top of that to take the
giant bag of points
and distill that down to
a vector space in the neural net part of
the software as opposed to the
heuristics part of the software
this is a big improvement
um you know that's all the way down
that's what you want it's not even your
own neural net but it's it's it's uh
this will be just a this is a game
changer to not have the bag of points
the giant bag of points that has to be
assembled with um many lines of cfc plus
loss uh and and have the
and have a neural net just assemble
those into a vector so so that the
neural net is outputting
um much much less data it's it's it's
outputting this this is a lane line this
is a curve this is drivable space this
is a car this is a
you know a
pedestrian or a cyclist or something
like that it's outputting
um
it's really outputting
um proper vectors to the
the cc plus plus control control code as
opposed to
the sort of
constructing the the vectors
uh in c
um
which we've done i think quite a good
job of but
it it's it's a it we're kind of hitting
a local maximum on the how well the c
can do this
so this is this is really this is really
a big deal
and and just all of the networks in the
car need need to move to surround video
there's still some legacy networks that
are not surround video um
and all of the training needs to move to
surround video and the efficiency of the
training uh it needs to get better and
it is
and then we need to move everything to
uh
raw
uh photon
counts as opposed to
processed images okay so which is just
quite a big reset on the training
because the system's trained on
post-processed image images so we need
to redo all the training
to train against the
raw photon accounts instead of the
post-processed image so ultimately it's
kind of reducing the complexity of the
whole thing so uh reducing reducing
lines of code will actually go lower
yeah that's fascinating
um so you're doing fusion of all the
sensors and reducing the complexity of
having to deal with these useful cameras
cameras really right yes
um
[Laughter]
same with humans
yeah well i guess we got ears too okay
yeah well we'll actually need to
incorporate um sound as well um because
you know you need to like listen for
ambulance sirens or you know fire trucks
plea you know uh or
somebody like
you know yelling at you or something i
don't know just there's there's a little
bit of audio that needs to be
incorporated as well
you